con el impuesto extraordinario a la
riqueza ha aprobado este viernes por el
congreso el gobierno argentino espera
recaudar por única vez unos 300 mil
millones de pesos algo así como 3 mil
600 millones de dólares para alcanzar
dependiendo de los cálculos a unas entre
9.000 y 12.000 personas con un
patrimonio superior a los 200 millones
de pesos algo así como 2 millones y
medio de dólares al cambio actual para
el gobierno esto es un impuesto especial
y extraordinario que implica un esfuerzo
que le pide a este sector más rico de la
población argumentando que en este
contexto de pandemia toda la población
todos los argentinos están haciendo un
gran esfuerzo la oposición considera que
es un impuesto que puede terminar
desincentivando las inversiones y muchas
de las personas alcanzadas por el
impuesto y gente que habla en su nombre
dice que puede ser confiscatorio porque
puede implicar que tengan que vender
alguno de sus bienes para poder pagarlo
o incluso que puede tratarse de doble
imposición porque en argentinas ya
existe un impuesto
personales se espera que muchas de estas
personas lleven esta causa a la justicia
y ahora quedan algunas preguntas
abiertas cuántos realmente pagarán el
impuesto cuánto se recaudará y será este
un impuesto realmente por única vez o se
volverá permanente